[Music]
um
how bad is it bad
we just lost contact with two of our
deep space outposts
there's something massive on long-range
scanners
is this what shepard warned us about
i just take my life on it
how long do we have
not long
i sent word to fleets of mobilizer
god help us all
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
commander
you're not supposed to call me that
anymore james
not supposed to salute you either we
gotta go the defense committee wants to
see you
sounds important
what's going on
couldn't say
just told me they needed you now
anderson
admiral you look good shepard maybe a
little soft around the edges how you
holding up since being relieved from
duty it's not so bad once you get used
to the hot food and soft beds
we'll get it sorted out what's going on
why is everyone in such a hurry admiral
hackett's mobilizing the fleets i'm
guessing words made it to alliance
command
something big's headed our way
the reapers
we don't know not for certain what else
could it be
if i knew that
it's the reapers
and we're not ready for them not by a
long shot
tell that to the defense committee
unless we're planning to talk the
reapers to death the committee is a
waste of time they're just scared
none of them have seen what you see
we've all reviewed your report seen the
data you've collected but it's all just
theory to us
you've been there in the trenches
fighting them
you know what they keep in love
that why they grounded me took away my
ship you know that's not true
the [__] you've done
any other soldier would have been tried
court-martialed and discharged
it's your knowledge of the reapers that
kept that from happening
that and your good word
yeah i trust you
and so does the committee i'm just a
soldier anderson i'm no politician i
don't need you to be either
i just need you to do whatever the hell
it takes to help us stop the rebounds
they're expecting you to admiral
good luck in there shepard
[Music]
anderson
shepard
ashley
lieutenant commander
i had to go in there
i can never tell with them i'm just
waiting for orders now
admiral
come on
[Music]
you know the commander
i used to
admiral anderson
shepard
what's the situation
we were hoping you would tell us
the reports coming in are unlike
anything we've seen our colonies have
gone dark we've lost contact with
everything beyond the soul relay
whatever this is
it's incomprehensibly powerful
you brought me here to confirm what you
already know
the reapers are here
[Music]
then
how do we stop them
stop them
this isn't about strategy or tactics
this is about survival
[Music]
the reapers are more advanced than we
are
more powerful more intelligent
they don't fear us
and they'll never take pity on us
but there must be some way
each of us has to be willing to die to
save humanity
anything less
and they've already won
that's it
that's our plan
admiral we've lost contact with luna
base
the moon
it couldn't be that close already
i'll they get past our defenses
sir uk headquarters has a visual
[Applause]
why haven't we heard from admiral
hackett
what do we do
the only thing we can
we fight
or we die
we should get to the normandy
oh my god
[Music]
uh
shepard
come on get up
here take this we've got to get moving
this is admiral anderson report it
anyway
lieutenant commander williams is that
you
what's your status
i can't raise the normal you'll have the
content we'll meet you at the landing
zone hand us enough
[Music]
they're massive
come on chum
ashley's headed to the normandy they'll
pick us up if we can get to the space
let's move
look out
how do you stop something so powerful
take a running jump it's farther than it
looks
come on let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
come on
we'll have to go this way
looks clear let's go
come on let's keep moving
lieutenant commander you read me
i'm patching in shepherd we're almost to
the normandy
with me
we're about five minutes husks
take him out
shoot him
i'm out of ammo
come on we gotta move
have to take these things out the
old-fashioned way
don't let him grab you
gotta find a way out of here
watch it
do this way
hey
[Music]
it's okay
everyone's dying
come here
i need to get you someplace safe
take my hand
you can't help me
shepard
in here
ah this is a goddamn mess
every minute these machines are here
thousands of innocent people die
i won't be responsible
you're not responsible for the ones that
die
we fight for the ones left standing when
it's all over
yeah
maybe you're right
it's so fast
i thought we got more time
we knew they were coming
and they still just cut through our
defenses
we need to go to the citadel
talk to the council
the citadel the fight's here
it'll be everywhere soon enough you said
it
yourself the reapers will destroy
everything if we don't stop them
the council has to help us
you sure about that
no but you were a council specter
that has to count for something
thanks
i owe you one
more than one
some ammo
reload let's keep
[Music]
lieutenant moving williams we're inside
of the spaceport
e.t.a three minutes
invasive maneuvers
lieutenant commander ashley
normally we're going to rerun do you
copy
normandy come in
friendlies
you two all right
get down they'll see you
keep your head
down
nice job
finish them all
over here
what happened here
our gunship was shot down we barely made
it
you have a radio
we're trying to contact our ship
no
there's one in the gun ship but it's
going to be crawling with those things
stay here son we'll get you out of here
come on
let's get to that gunship
what the hell
[Music]
ah
shepard over here
i found a radio
normandy this is anderson do you read
admiral what's your location
by a downed gun chip in the harbor i'm
activating his distress beacon
sensor door we've got wounded
[Applause]
let's hope that beacon does its job
and fast we've got company
[Music]
hope they get there soon
you and me folks
running out of ammo
[Music]
there's more of them
about time
let's go
[Music]
hmm
back shepard
thanks
shepard
come on
i'm not going
you saw those men back there there's a
million more like them and they need a
leader we're in this fight together
anderson
it's a fight we can't win not without
help
we need every species and all their
ships to even have a chance at defeating
the reapers
talk to the council
convince them to help us
what if they won't listen
then make them listen
now go that's an order
i don't take orders from you anymore
remember
consider yourself reinstated
commander
you know what you have to do
i'll be back for you and i'll bring
every fleet i can
good luck
you too shepherd
[Music]
[Applause]
what the hell's going on where's
anderson where are we going
hey
we're leaving
leaving
what's going on
anderson wants us to go to the citadel
get help for the fight
[__] he wouldn't order us to leave
we don't have a choice
without help this war is already over
forget it drop me off someplace cause
i'm not enough
don't you think i'd rather stay and
fight
we're going to the citadel you want out
you can catch a ride back from there
commander
joker that you alive and kicking got an
emergency transmission from admiral
hackett
patching through
anderson's already ordered me to the
citadel to talk to the council
[Music]
yes sir
joker set a course for the mars archives
mars
roger then
this is local
why mars what does he think we'll find
there
i don't know yet
but if it helps us win this war
grab your gear
[Music]
i've been trying to reach mars on secure
channels
no one's answering
any sign of reaper activity
we're almost there
still no contact from the base but we've
got a massive storm headed our way
how long till it hits
half hour tops after that we're gonna
have difficulty keeping up calms with
the normandy
understood
damn that's a huge storm looks a lot
bigger
person
come on lieutenant it's not that bad
doesn't mean it can't kill us i'm more
worried about the war back on earth or
the fact that nobody here is reporting
in
fair enough
what's that
alliance sergeant reeves doesn't look
like he put up a fight
something's not right here keep a low
profile till we know what's going on
holy [__] they're executing them
it's a clear shot
i know we're here now
[Music]
those guys were cerberus weren't they
sure looked like it
what's cerberus doing here on mars
good question
you don't know
i'm not with them anymore ash if that's
what you're asking it wasn't
but we've got a shadowy terrorist
organization
it doesn't look like
they came here in force
yeah just a few vehicles kinda suggest
they had help from the inside
seemed likely you need a lot more men
and firepower to take this place
otherwise
i need a straight answer shepard
about what
servers may be pro-human but they're no
friend of the alliance do you know what
they're doing here
what makes you think i know what they're
up to
you worked for them how am i supposed to
believe you've cut all ties
let me be clear i didn't work for them i
worked with them and i don't anymore
and i have no idea why they're here now
or what they want
commander shepard's been under constant
surveillance since coming back to earth
no way they've communicated since
sorry shepard
[Music]
you want to hate cerberus fine but i'm
done explaining myself to you
are we clear
of course i didn't mean to
uh
yes
easy there lieutenant cheese with us
shepard thank the goddess you're alive
liara
i was worried when the reports came in
they hit earth hard
yeah
it was
difficult to leave
ashley
i'm sorry
but why do you come here
hack it ordered us to come said you'd
know what was going on
i do
hallelujah some answers finally
maybe i've discovered plans for a
prothean device one that could wipe out
the reapers
here on mars
in the prothean archives yes
i guess i'll believe it when i see it
where do we find this weapon
it's not a weapon not yet it's plans for
a device a blueprint
it's more than we had a minute ago how
do we get it
the archives are just across that
tramway
assuming cerberus hasn't locked it down
what are they after
yeah they seem hell bent on catching you
they want what i'm here for
what we're all here for
but why
the protheans came close to defeating
the reapers they had plans to destroy
them but ran out of time
and anything powerful enough to destroy
the reapers
just might be something cerberus would
be interested in
so it's a race to the archives
we've got company
bring it on
not this time james
what
get back to the show cerberus beats us
to the archives i need you covering the
exits
but
now
they're getting closer we should take
cover
[Music]
looks like they found us
you can't hide forever
you're going to need more than guns to
finish them shepard
that's all of them
good let's find a way up
this is a secure station how did servers
get in
not sure
one minute we were getting reports of
the reaper invasion
the next there was chaos didn't even
realize it was cerberus at first
could they be working with the reapers
doubtful but i suppose anything's
possible
oh
uh
[Music]
we'll need access to the pedway control
should be nearby
damn it security's been tempered with
shepard see if you can gain access to
the pedway
i can't seem to unlock the live feeds
but
hey did you see that
who's that woman in the vid
that's dr ivakare she got here about a
week
ago any luck
headway's been locked out
all right looks like there's
construction nearby we can get out on
the roof
we can find a way around from there
great let's move
store's getting
what the hell
looks like the alliance is still putting
up a fight
that tram heads to the archives once
service is across they're at the final
security checkpoint
and that's where we're headed
[Music]
barely storms causing interference
doesn't look like it was forced
no you have to override security
protocols
someone vented the air from this room
while they were still here
looks like they died trying to call
their way out
this is brutal even by cerberus
standards
flashlights
what's our order
there's an alliance force in here
somewhere we need to keep them away from
the core
we need to pressurize the room first
[Music]
there we go
we have access to the labs they'll take
us right to the tram station
hey looks like there's a recording of
what happened here
security station
come in we're seeing some odd activity
down here
our security protocols just kicked in
everything's locked down
doctor i'll get you a report
[Music]
i guess we know how cerberus got in
i should have realized it when i met her
i was just so focused on finding a way
to stop the reapers
you did what needed to be done
right now i need you to get us to the
archives
through the door we're getting close
nice
let's move
[Music]
do you read me
reinforcements
oh
[Music]
um
oh
[Music]
uh
what's that smell
they just activated the decontamination
protocols with the staff still inside
[Music]
foreign
this is where they studied the various
relics on earth here
what did they find
more than i could describe in a short
conversation
and they'd only scratched the surface
there are vaults filled with prothean
data droves that have never been studied
so
that's the trend line takes us right to
the archives
no doubt service has it locked down
hopefully we can override it at the
security station
it's just through here
[Music]
no kidding is that the only way in
it's the only way i know of
we'll skirt around stay out of its
sights
i'll move up first
don't let it target you
[Music]
it
get me out of here
[Music]
stay in cover shepard
the turret can't fire on us from here
[Music]
got it
uh
looks like they've made it to the
archives
and it looks like they won't be sending
a tram anytime soon
can you override it
the archives are on a separate network
we're completely locked out
not completely
what if we could find a short-range
transmitter helmet to helmet
and
and then we convinced them that we're
with them and the alliance forces have
been taken care of
good idea see what you can find
what
the lieutenant commander has become very
capable
agreed
commander i found something
what have you got
he's got a transmitter in his helmet if
i can
oh
oh god
he looks like a husk yeah not quite
but they've definitely done something to
him
they
you mean cerberus
they did this to their own people
can you see why i'm worried about you
worry about the reapers
the war
we need to focus if we're gonna stop
them
yes sir
come on
let's see if we can get them to send
that tram over
hello this is
delta team
anybody there
where the hell have you been
never mind what's your status
we're at the tram station waiting for
extraction all hostiles terminated roger
that echo team will ride over and secure
the station
think they bought it
if they didn't they'll figure it out
soon enough
we should get in position flank them
when they get off the tram
good thinking elsie
i will
okay
i'm on it
on it
ah
not
storm's getting bad we better wrap this
up quickly
the archives are right at the other side
that in the squad of pissed off service
troops
do
[Music]
they put up a good fight
yes it confirms my assertions about the
value of the data stored here
ah
[Music]
come on
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
uh
um
[Music]
uh
ash
[Music]
so
shepherd
elusive man
now we know why cerberus is here
you don't know the half of it the
prophets left us these archives a wealth
of information and it's been squandered
what do you want
[Music]
what i've always wanted
the data in these artifacts
holds the key to solving the reaper
threat i've seen your solution your
people are turned into monsters
partly they're being improved
improved
that's what separates us shepard where
you see a means to destroy
i see a way to control to dominate and
harness the reaper's
power imagine how strong humanity would
be
if we controlled them
you've gone too far
the reapers will kill us all if we don't
stop fighting each other
i don't expect you to understand shepard
and i'm certainly not looking for your
approval
i needed your help once
just as you needed mine
[Music]
but like the rest of the relics in this
place
your time is over
enough talk
we are
don't interfere with my plan shepard
i won't warn you again
duly noted
shepherd
what
the data it's not here
[Music]
it's being erased
goodbye
damn it how's he doing
it's local someone's uploading the
information
hey
step away from the console
now
[Music]
she's got the data
she's faster than she looks
stay close we can't lose her
there she is
she's getting away
watch out
has the data
radio the normandy get them down here
now
[Music]
i got this one
they'll be here soon
we need the data
[Music]
orders
finisher
[Music]
grab that thing bring it with us shepard
we got reaper signatures in orbit
ash
ashley
[Music]
you